[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
ryan is sitting down it feels more
authentic this way doesn't it
oh it does it's just natural it's like
ryan's in his natural habitat when we
catch him
sitting down we don't want to be too
clean here too perfect
it's impossible for us to be perfect or
at least for me to be perfect
and you caught me not being perfect so
there we go yeah
hey folks uh if you're tuned in because
you're excited about mandalorians katie
sakhoff i thank you from the bottom of
my heart
sincerely may not sound sincere but i'm
very sincere
but please uh subscribe and um stick
around for other guests
uh you know i notice we get a huge jump
on certain guests
and then some people decide to leave but
you'd hope that they liked the
interview enough that they go hey i'll
give this guy a chance
right that's what the goal is that's the
hope yeah well i'm hoping for that
so anybody who's a katy sackoff fan
including me including ryan
will stick around and subscribe and
where uh can they subscribe on youtube
uh youtube.com slash inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
is the one inside of you with
with michael rosenbaum that's you what
is it again the beginning
youtube.com youtube.com
slash insider inside of you with michael
rose and then on uh
you can subscribe on apple and please
leave a review
it helps the algorithm and all that
stuff i'm not going to just dwell on it
but if you could just do that it takes
10 seconds to write a review if you like
the show
um what are the handles here on social
well inside of you pod on twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook that's right and
uh the new band sunspin is out um our
album's coming out
and we're very excited i just played a
few songs for you and you were i think
surprised
a couple yeah i mean because i've heard
them in all stages and so it's always
nice to hear the full
product mastered version and um yeah i
was a big fan of your friend blake lewis
yeah because in fact um i could play a
little something yeah
is called barrel of the gun this is the
chorus
[Music]
trumpet oh yeah
staring
[Music]
staring down
well we're really excited about this we
just had it mastered and uh
had a lot of great performers on the on
the album a lot of great musicians i'm
directing the summertime neighbor video
that's a song on the album
we're directing that socially distance
on sunday um we're really excited the
the the uh please follow us the handles
are at sunspin band
on instagram twitter facebook and uh the
new website has tons of merch like lunch
boxes and
places to book the band and zoom and all
that stuff
and that is just sunspin.com sunspin.com
so we'd love to support and we're
playing a big show on stage it so you
can watch from the
comforts of your own home on january
30th 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific standard
time
two shows saturday january 30th go to
stageh.com and type in sunspin and
support us be part of the big family
and uh follow us on there so sunspin
sunspin.com um yeah
and i'm also doing those cameo videos
they're doing like the live
you could actually do like zooms so i'm
actually talking to people on cameo now
it's not just me leaving a message
it's pretty neat i actually like it i i
reserve a like a a spot like on
wednesday
or thursday from like 6 to 6 30 and i
just talk to people for you know
whatever and
it's a blast some people ask me
questions like this girl michelle
michelle king hi
she asked me trivia questions yeah is
fun
i have a good time look great yeah and
also join uh patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you
and uh become a part of the patreon
family the patron family
um so many great tiers of like if some
folks get merch every couple months some
people get to ask questions to the
guests [ __ ] talking questions to the
guests
um private uh
youtube live where i play live concerts
just for you and
get you it's like a request line it's a
lot of fun uh very excited about today's
show i want to thank my
former guests uh tom welling the the
episode just crushed and
uh it was really exciting ernie hudson
from ghostbusters what a great episode
that was if you get a chance to listen
to it please
listen to it you're going to love it you
learned so much and
uh it was touching it was fun and i
didn't know ernie at all
and uh i wanted i want to be a son after
that
why don't we just get into i you know
i've been friends with her you've seen
her in battle star galactic you've seen
in
many other shows but this mandalorian
really
was the is a role that is probably the
most famous
the biggest role she'll probably get
right it's really good it was really
cool
i mean an integral part too that she has
i mean i
finally watched all the episodes after
talking to her and i was blown away by
the the role that she has in the
mandalorians so uh
she's a wonderful actress a wonderful
woman
and uh thank you i want to thank you
right now katie for um
doing the podcast and without further
ado let's get inside of katie
sackoff it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you're not married you have a fiance not
married yet we are waiting for
our visa from the american government to
go through
oh so he's not an american yeah where's
what's his name robin robin
yeah you've been dating a while right
is he there i mean it just feels like
you're looking it over like
do you care that i said i'm not wearing
a bra robin is everything okay
no literally he just before i was like
getting to ready to do this he's like
helena he calls these my fluffs
your feet your flips are on point babe
you may want to
where is he from he is from a small town
in the interior of british columbia oh
okay so he doesn't have an accent
really no okay he's not like he's not
that foreign
not that far i thought you were because
he was like you're fluffs i was
imagining him talking
your fluffs are fluffy but he's not he's
not not that foreign he just says your
fluffs are um
a little on on they're going a little
crazy right
is that your christmas tree behind you
the one that's about uh one foot long to
over your right shoulder
i am surrounded by
boxes right now i literally i'm
surrounded by boxes
yeah it's crazy it's stressful isn't it
it is stressful and it's like you know
robin and i
we we really decided to test our
relationship
this this quarantine um
i think that the moment we started
dating practically we were
renovating a house together um
renovating a house we work together we
live together
like you know it's um it's
it's pretty crazy the fact that we're
still together we were doing our prenup
and
the the lawyer said that she was she was
happy that we were still getting married
because we were the only ones
prenup like so you know usually people
don't talk about prenups like
uh in fact i've talked to therapists of
mine and
you know if you're dating a girl or a
guy or whatever you
you think you know shouldn't i protect
myself or protect us both and how do you
sort of talk about prenups do you
you know and one of my thoughts was look
i'm not saying i'm gonna fall out of
love with you
i'm i'm protecting myself because most
likely you are gonna fall out of love
with me
so this is why we're doing this i'm
confident this will last
for eternity but what is
what who brought it up and and and how
do you do that so
the the reason you know you always enter
into a relationship
anticipating it's gonna last forever i
think that that would be ridiculous to
do to do so if you had
any other thought in your mind um
but you have to protect yourself and so
for me it's not
it's not even about protecting myself
for him protecting himself
it's about you know my my parents have
worked incredibly hard
and they're both very self-made and
they've done very well for themselves in
the development and real estate market
in portland
and a lot of that stuff is left to my
brother and my sister
and all of their grandchildren and that
stuff needs to be
protected um because it's not about me
it's about
um it's about it's about my brother and
sister and
and and my nieces and nephews good angle
what a great angle to say listen this
isn't even about me
this is about my folks and i well
it is no i know but like that's a good
way to a good segue
it's true though and then you've got to
do weird things like you've got you know
you're like i've got eggs and storage
like all of these things that you've
you've actually got to talk about
because
you know is i think that people
sometimes
they forget that marriage and i know
this sounds awful
but marriage is a is a business deal it
really is
it's the coming together of two
companies rather
um and you have to be pragmatic about
things you can
you can be as romantic as you want to be
i love this man more than anything
in in the world and and i formally
believe we're going to be together
forever
um but you also have to understand that
it's not just about you so many times
you know um and i think that
that i don't know i just think it's
smart where did you meet
robin we met at work of course which
what movie
yeah no we met on another life and i was
just gonna say another live with justin
chatwin
yeah with chatwin so you met me
so was it the first day where you're
like i don't know if you're doing a
table read or
i don't know if you're on set and
there's this guy that walks in and
you're like
whoa i'm attracted to that guy and he
looks at you and all of a sudden it's
early
and you're like well i don't have many
scenes with him so we can kind of [ __ ]
around
i mean what is it he's not an actor so
like
whoa did he direct it no
no so robin um is a writer
um and one of his friends worked in the
production office
and he was looking for a way to
sort of like get back into the film
industry
and so he took a low level position on
our production
to sort of like get himself out of
managing a bar
and writing during the day it was a
cycle that he wasn't excited about he
was working all night and trying to
write during the day it was just
not the healthiest thing so he took this
job to have a normal
life in normal hours and you know we met
and i had nine months before
gotten out of a relationship that ended
so terribly
and i had just gotten to a point where
i've gone through
therapy and i've accepted like my
part in it that was the star track guy
right yeah
we wanted to get in there yeah what was
his name i forgot uh not
carl carl carl right so yeah whatever
whatever just it just didn't end great
relationships mostly don't
didn't end great you know what's funny
it's it's it's um
well we don't talk about it but um so it
had taken me a long time to get to a
point where i was like
all right and i truly thought that this
guy was gonna be a rebound
um because i was finally ready
to i was looking at men again like for
the first time
in like nine months i was like oh he's
cute
he's cute right feels good
i really thought that i was protecting
myself because he's 10 years younger
than me and i was like
so he's 10. could you imagine
no michael he's 18. oh oh oh you're 28.
holy okay i get that but you know the
thing i keep thinking about is
is he moving boxes on set is he saying
excuse me uh ma'am i'm just trying to
move the cables out here and you're like
oh god he's got great feet what what
what
was it he he was a production assistant
and and he
you know he was just we just became like
best friends and like i love this
really got to know each other on a
deeper level
um and that was all it was and then when
production was over
i just remember thinking myself i kept
saying to my mother like repeatedly
this guy's gonna make some woman so
happy one day
he is the most amazing person i've ever
met in my entire life wow
and i just kept saying that he's just so
smart he's so
kind like he's just like everything he's
amazing
wow he's gonna make some woman so happy
and my mom was like what is wrong with
you and i was like i don't what are you
talking about
um and i was like oh no he's 10 years
younger than me she was like
i don't understand what is wrong with
you child wow so mom was a cheerleader
yeah yeah and i think that i think that
my mom was finally
um she saw someone that treated me well
and and um and that was that was
new wow yeah yeah
you know i think that she just went oh
my god this this
this man is inherently kind like i've
dated
nice guys before like they're nice they
know how to put it on they're nice i've
never
met a guy who's just innately [ __ ]
kind
you know like just really kind um
and it still blows my mind i wake up
every morning and like pinch myself that
i'm lucky enough to be loved by this
person it just blows my mind
did your mother afterwards say what's
what's age what's this
blah blah he's so nice he's gonna make
you happy and then go
but definitely do the prenup because
it's our property
you definitely have to i know she didn't
do that come on it's funny
my parents have never in their minds
it was it was always it was a it was a
thing it was this
it was a thing with my brother and my
sister and i that if if and when
we any of us got married it was a
non-negotiable or everything was going
to be pulled out of your name it was
like it was not
this is not a like we highly recommend
this is a you will do this
or you know we'll have to protect
ourselves in other ways
right i i will say this i i've known you
for a long time but i haven't like you
know we've never been close we're kind
of like just
friendly and there was something just
nice and we just like you know it was
just a nice rapport you know everybody
in hollywood are friends but i really
like
like somebody says katie i'm like oh man
she's the best and you really are
a wonderful person you could tell when
you meet you you tell when you meet you
whatever you're just like there's just
something
again innately good about you and it's
nice that you feel the same way about
the
the man you you fell in love with and
well it's true and
you know when i look at your like your
life your career and i'm like
there's certain people i look at and go
god that person doesn't stop working but
you not only do not stop working it's
more than that it's more than you don't
stop working hard you don't stop
you just keep whatever you're in you're
busting your ass and want to be the best
you are
and so like this break that you just had
with mandalorian
you know and i know everybody's talking
about and all of a sudden you're like oh
everybody wants to talk to me now
you know that's how i feel whenever you
get something like oh michael what are
you i'm like oh yeah oh yeah but you're
like yeah i'm available
overnight success i mean and you're not
an overnight six you've been
pounding the pavement for a long time
and so
it's just really cool that you're doing
something
i mean you've done great work and things
that you get excited about
but i know from talking to you that you
know star wars
is is part of i mean it's beyond pop
culture it's like
omnipresent it's everywhere you look
it's just if my agent called and said
you got star wars you're gonna do star
wars i mean i i honestly i'm not kidding
if i never worked again that'd be fine
if i did star wars yeah
somebody said spielberg's putting you in
a movie and they said that this is the
last time you'll ever act
fine i'm in fine if you're gonna work
with de niro i'm done
did you audition for this because an
audition alone to me would be
a pretty big feat pretty big right no
i i didn't so so here's the crazy thing
is that i
when i was a little kid i idolized
male action stars because there were not
a lot of
female ones in the 80s um i mean we had
the sigourney weavers and we had the
you know the linda hamiltons and the
lucy lawlesses but we also had
princess leia who was smart
and feisty and gorgeous and
um a ball buster and capable and
caring and like so well-rounded
um and so from a young age
i loved star wars i mean it was
i i always joked that i when i first
moved to
to california i said to my agent now
look
there's only one thing i'll always do if
they call me to be a
rock in a star wars movie just say yes
i'll be a rock that's all i mean just to
be in this world
um and so when dave filoni when they
when the offer came in about
more than 10 years now to do the voice
of bogotan
right clone wars yeah um i jumped like i
didn't even
it wasn't even like i think twice it was
like of course that's amazing
a female mandalorian warrior um a hello
of course and i remember
multiple times as we were sort of doing
this dave and i joking
about you know one day
um if this happens you know she could
exist in these worlds you know and i
just
kept sort of saying tongue-in-cheek
things like that because
i honestly was just taking the piss i
never
like you see amazing things and and i'm
not gonna say that amazing things
haven't happened in my career
i've had such a beautiful career i work
my ass off
um but i have had a beautiful career and
there have been great things
but you see i've seen people around me
get that big huge massive thing you know
and you go
wow so proud of them so excited for them
it's amazing because if it happens to
someone else
there's still hope right but it can
happen to you
but it's never happened to me like it
never like that big
huge thing had never happened so
i always joked with him just thinking of
course they'll recast it they'll
probably hire scarlett johansson or
something like that
um but when mandalorian came out and i
saw him
at um at a celebration
i made a joke about you know
bogutan wink wink nudge nudge i said you
know i've
been playing characters like this for 15
years buddy
um and i never i never really thought it
would happen
um i was just sort of joking well let me
ask you this before i want you to finish
this because i love it yeah but what i
think of is
name one actor
who has played the animated version of a
character and then the live action
i i haven't i've never played lex luthor
animated
i've never played flash live action in
fact
lex luthor's been recast in in many ways
i haven't been considered
i'm not angry probably am but was or
but anyway yeah so this is i can't name
one so the fact that you were boca raton
i'm just kidding i know florida
it's a phase two phase two book every
time
but um playing bokeh tan
as the voice and then playing getting
the live action it's just
no it's unheard of they never do it no
one has a because no one thinks outside
the box no one thinks
it's not even outside the box no one
thinks inside the box no one just goes
of course look at this actress but
anyway but continue
yeah no i i think sometimes they think
that if you hit the nail on the head
um it was too easy and it wasn't
inspired enough
for some reason um so they tried to
think outside the box so much so
um that they sometimes get it wrong i
guess and they sometimes get it right
um but yeah it was this moment where i
was always just joking and
when a phone call came in that john
favreau wanted to sit down with me
i almost had a heart attack i
it took me halfway through that meeting
to realize that he was actually talking
about
me doing bokeh tan
i i just i i remember sitting across
from him total out of body experience i
remember sitting across from him
and just thinking to myself this is
what is he is he oh those are pictures
of me on the wall why
why are there what is happening oh he's
still talking wait what is he talking
about
what is going on like it was it was
crazy
um and i still to this day i'm still
pinching myself my mind is blown that
not only
did they have the thought to do this but
that they they
they believed that i could and then they
they ultimately let me
did they did he offer you the role in
the room uh
yeah i think so what did he say like
what what was it what
was it okay was it a hey so would you do
this
i think it was something like that and
like i said i was so
out of body i really
i don't remember um but i do believe it
was something along
um the lines of like now is this
something you would be interested in
like don't
don't feel like you have to say yes but
is this something that you
that interests you did you play in cool
did you try to play
it's not i think i feed over the table
and i like
touched my finger on the table and i was
like you gotta be kidding me
like of course i'll do this like i think
i was so
shocked did he smile did he say all
right all right
of course he did oh my god he's such a
warm
oh yeah he's awesome john's awesome
amazing
and he's such a phenomenal director and
he's a
fantastic actor and he's you know one of
the things that i loved
love about working with him so much as
he has this beautiful way of
giving you direction that is
motivating and exciting um
even if it's if it's a critique on what
you did it doesn't come across
as a fatigue it comes across as um
hey that was amazing i'm so excited
let's go over here because this is
exciting too
um and he just naturally does it and
it's it's a
beautiful he's he's so good at what he
does
i want i want to actually say thank you
to john favreau right now because
star wars you know it's you know for me
and
and millions and millions of others it's
it's
it's so close to home and it's just it
is home and it's and then so some of
those new
the prequels and things like that they
didn't necessarily hit it and i was
people were frustrated and this and that
there's a lot of reasons and some were
better than others
but when i watched the mandalorian and
expecting
probably something similar i was
absolutely blown away to the point where
i
felt like a child again watching
the jawas for the first time watching
these these
it just was the practicals the vision
extraordinary if you haven't watched the
mandalorian you are
missing out even if you're not a star
wars fan it doesn't matter it's so well
made
so well directed produced written acted
and now
katie sackoff is playing beau catan and
just a little history
first before we get to the history of
boca tan because i want to talk a little
bit about that
but i wish there was a camera on your
face when you walked out
you're you're back to him to favro
walking out to your car because i
what i do know about you is that you
probably got in your car and probably
teared up and got really excited
and gave yourself some fist bumps and
like oh my god i wanted to call
robin immediately and say forget about
the prenup listen
this is the this it went so well i think
i might have got it i don't know i don't
want to jinx it but i think i did
i don't know what would you do i think i
still at that moment like i'm
i i try to be really self-aware a lot
and i think i remember thinking to
myself
they could still see you they could
still see you they could still see you
i could just drive away drive away i
like started the car
and like you know i kept trying to put
it in like drive and i hadn't even like
you know turned the car on yet and i
kept trying to like
like okay and i just got far enough away
where they couldn't see me
and i called robin and i was like oh my
god
i don't even know i don't know i don't
know and i kept going i don't know i
don't know i don't know
i don't know let's wait that's what we
do yeah yeah i would have put the bee
geez on
blasting into that song like here i am
waiting for this moment tonight
knowing i don't know
inside of you is brought to you by geico
michael do you rent or own your home i
own my home ryan i bet it could be
difficult
it is very difficult i mean the one
thing that everybody worries about is
always paying your mortgage or paying
your rent that's something that's very
difficult and uh you know insurance and
all the stuff that goes along with that
you know what's easy what bundling your
policies with geico
bundling bundling now you're talking
about bundling we've talked about this
but this is very important to me because
i can't
if you do too many things if you're
paying three different insurance
companies what does that do for you it
stresses you out you're writing a lot of
checks you're writing you're using your
credit card you don't know where things
are coming from
but bundling you could do them all
together auto
mortgage all these things right all of
it all together all in one place
with geico with geico there's a reason
why everybody knows the word
geico the name geico because even a
rosenbaum can do it
and that's me so get your bundling
policy
go to geico.com today
that's guycode.com it's geico easy
inside of you is brought to you by
wondery wundry's new true crime podcast
the apology line begins with alan bridge
posting flyers around new york city
asking people to anonymously apologize
for their crimes
not to god not to the police but to his
answering machine
within hours the calls start coming in
people apologizing for stealing
infidelity
lying and even murder allen got dozens
of calls from people claiming to be
murderers but
one stood out richie he was deliberate
measured and his calls would leave
thousands wondering if he really was the
serial killer he claimed to be
that is until richie offered to provide
proof of his crimes
unable to just listen anymore allen knew
he had to try and stop him
if you're listening to the audio version
of our show stick around to the end to
hear a preview of the apology line
or you can listen right now on apple
podcasts
what i love is is the excitement i love
i hate
cool i hate being cool i'm not cool i'm
not i hate when people try to be
i love you're always a person you wear
your uh emotions on your
whatever you you just like i like seeing
you excited i like seeing a person
excited about what they love
and their dreams coming true and
whatever happens with boca tan cause
bokutan is an important part but um
i just think it's it's awesome and i'm
glad someone like you
got it because you appreciate it so much
you know i've had on my show another
life right now i
i am i made a decision um when i took
this job
that i would be positive every single
day that i would come to work
and i would be a leader that
was optimistic all the time
um because i've worked and i have been
the opposite
you know i've i've been the person that
needed to be called out on set for my
attitude
um whoa whoa really you yeah what kind
of added
when did this happen and what
adjustments did you make so
you know the thing with me as you said i
wear my heart on my sleeve
um i when i'm in a
bad mood i have a really hard time
hiding it and
i had it was the first season of
longmire
i'd come right off of riddick and we
were doing night shoots and i was
exhausted
and i went straight into early morning
days in freezing cold weather during
longmire
in season one and um it was cold and i
got sick
and um and
bailey chase and i would drive to work
together because we would we were always
outside the limit which
we about 60 miles every morning and
i would complain all the time about you
know i
i just felt like i was being
underutilized on the show
and i was disappointed and i didn't um
i didn't want to go complain because god
god forbid you'd go and actually have
an adult conversation with someone i
just wanted to [ __ ] about it all the
time
um and i was also not in a great spot in
my life i was in a relationship
that lasted too long and and i should
have i should have left and i was just
not a very happy
person and he called me out
in front of the entire crew one day and
it was until this day i
you know he and i finally made up
because it was not
good for a while because i was so
disappointed in the way that he did it
you know
my mind was do it offset have this
conversation with me offset don't do it
in front of the crew
um but it taught me the one of the
biggest lessons of my career
and i realized that i had a choice
and i had to change my perspective and i
needed to grow the
f up um what did he say to you
in front of the crew he screamed at me
and said be here
want to be here i am so tired of you
you know and i don't really remember
what he said but it was it was loud and
it was
it was um and i always thought it was
the wrong time in the wrong place i was
very angry that he did it that way but
it needed to happen and it woke me up
and it made me realize that
that the attitude i bring to set every
day is the attitude
that permeates the set because for
better or worse i have the ability
i think because i'm so big and i'm loud
and my voice carries like
that i have the ability to change the
set i can make it a positive place to be
or a negative place to be
and i i
was wrong i was very wrong and i had to
learn that lesson
yeah and i learned two things i learned
i needed to stand up for myself so i
went in and i started talking to the
producers about what i wanted the
character to be
um but i also realized that i needed to
be the person that people wanted to work
with twice
it couldn't be the person that um
took it for granted i was taking it for
granted and i
needed to be called out and he did it
and then
by the end of the the series
the producers all you know said
they would work with me again i i went i
did a complete 180
purposefully but i taught myself how to
to be happy and how to
enjoy what i'm doing daily and to not
focus on the things that are out of your
control
um and that
i have the ability to to
to change the course of the day on set
i want it to be a good place or a bad
place i have that i have that power
and um for whatever reason probably just
because i'm one of the actors and and so
you're front and center
if you're in a bad mood it's very
obvious and so
i took that into another life and i i
wanted to be that person that showed up
every day
worked harder than everybody else but
was always positive and was always
motivating and um and so the
the younger actors on the show it's the
one thing that they
and i don't even remember why i brought
this up um but it was it's the one thing
that they say to me all the time is that
you're just
always in such a good mood and i tell
them it's a choice
every day you come to work it's a choice
this is such a gift that we get to do
this
and maybe it's because i'm 40 and i've
been doing this since i was
you know 14 and now i finally i have
that
that hindsight already
realize how lucky i am because i've been
doing it long enough to know
it's a lot of people aren't that that
lucky
well you know what's crazy about this is
this story is so
it's personal and it's it's a journey
but i think it will help a lot of people
in fact i was sitting there going
i should write this down wait i could
just rewind it
but then i thought this is a lesson in
life this isn't just
you on set it's great that it worked out
for you because i'm i'm
sure that changing that whole
perspective makes you feel healthier
physically and mentally
it changes the game when you can
separate okay this is how i
feel this is this being you know in a
bad mood
and by the way driving an hour to work
and back
and working 12 or 14 hours days i
flipped myself i mean i'd be like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] me you're all out of line
it was a hard show it was well i'm sure
it was and you actually emailed me a
long time ago would you consider being
in this
for a role or like one of the leads i
think you did you go hey
you know you'd be in yeah and i couldn't
do it but it sounds like
it was a good call because those hours
you know what it was
crazy it was crazy however
if you watch longmire it's one of the
reasons why people love it the
cinematography
oh yeah it looks great all right and the
reason it looks great is you have to
drive an hour to find it
yeah and you were a cop you had to wear
the cop outfit anyway
what i'm saying though the the life
lesson is
no matter where you are out there you
have a choice
you could go work at mcdonald's i worked
at mcdonald's
you could work at mcdonald's and go [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that
i [ __ ] hate their food people are
dicks
i you know i didn't get my counter
button that uh you know
and you could do that and you it's
understandable you can say hey i know
they're paying you [ __ ] you got to work
for like
and it's a low paying job and but if you
change your perspective
i know it's difficult and it's coming
from a different place because who am i
to say but i've worked at these places
if you're going with a good attitude the
day's just going to be better for you
forget everything else if you're just
going you know what i'm not happy but
i'm not going to bring it here because
this is going to be a longer
more painful more just unhealthy day and
it's going to put more stress on my body
it is a choice that if you can go and
say hey i'm going to make the most of it
i'm going to steal some cheeseburgers
before i leave
i'm going to mcgrib's back you know
things are
looking up so i mean it is a choice and
i i've been there i have
i went through a stage where i was just
like not happy to be there and people
was are you all right i go yup
fine i'm fine man good to see you man
good morning but but they knew
where's rosie rosie's always doing
stand-up comedy and making the guys
laugh
and showing his ass which you can't do
anymore so so all these things
and i look back i wasn't mad at the crew
i never treated them mistreated
but i was mad at you know the studio for
treating me like [ __ ] in negotiations
and treating me like
nothing and not making me feel important
but i had nothing to do with anything on
set
and i wasted so much time yeah and the
studio doesn't care
they don't care on a daily basis that
are feeling that you know
yeah it truly it
truly does matter you know it really
does matter how we treat people at work
and i
i um and i learned that lesson and it
was
it was not an easy lesson to learn it
was it was
hard it's hard having somebody
yell at you in front of an entire crew
when they're right uh i did that once i
yelled at someone and i was right
yeah and i and i hated to do it i hated
it katie i [ __ ]
i didn't want to do it it was one of
these things many years ago
where i was in my trailer
and the guy the first ads or second
third eight
whatever came up to me and said hey
rosie we need you on set i'm like
awesome
walked right out went on set and we're
there and the whole crew and the cast is
there
sitting down and i walked in i go hey
you guys having a party without me
and one of the actors says no we're
actually waiting for you
because you're late and we're you know
and that was his
sort of thing and i go what
and then the director's like hey rosie
let's just let's just do this i go no no
hang on first
and the person kept going on and i go
yeah uh well first of all no no i gotta
let this out i can't cause i'm not now
i'm in a bad mood okay
i can't just sit down and be a puppet
and do this because that's not how i
operate i want to get this out
first of all you're wrong i'm always on
set before everybody else
i always know my [ __ ] i was in my
trailer and how long did it take john
when you came to my trailer and asked me
okay 30 seconds so either some there's a
miscommunication
but for you to lash out at me is [ __ ]
rude and
you owe me an apology and i was pissed
and
and the person just looked at me with
these eyes like and couldn't say
anything and i go okay i got
i got it out let's let's make funny yeah
and then about an hour later the person
came to my trailer and we talked about i
go hey listen man just i'm sorry for i
should have snapped at you but you
snapped at me and i should have just
taken the higher road and
and we were we were fine and it needed
to happen though i mean
you know but look we didn't christian
bail people
you know we didn't [ __ ] you know tom
cruise everybody
but look um but look we we learned our
lesson and we're growing and that's all
we can do as humans is try to [ __ ]
grow
you know where i'm not perfect i'm an
idiot
i just like you know i'm gonna make a
mistake and say hey rosie it's all right
don't do it again all right
you know what i mean absolutely but and
that's the thing to admit you're wrong
is huge most people can't admit they're
wrong like
it is it has become a game not a game
but like a
prideful thing with me when somebody
calls me on something or somebody says
something i go oh my god thank you so
much you're right i'm wrong
it's it is what it is you know robin did
it last night just about
every time i say do you like this and he
says no i get really upset and he's like
hey you you know and very respectfully
said
you're teaching me to not tell you what
i think and i was like oh my god
you're right you're right and i'm so
sorry that i need to work on that let me
work on that
but thank you for telling me that um
that's good
because we're not perfect we all make
mistakes no but it is what it is and
so everything is a gift this is a huge
gift my my mind is blown
that i am an action figure like all of
that right will you sign me one and send
me one
they're sold out well when they when
they get them back i'll pay for it if i
send it to you you sign it and send it
back
absolutely awesome and also get the uh
mandalorian the main mandalorians
autograph
please um you know i know you said it
was the hardest secret i saw some
interviews we don't have to get that it
was a big secret you had to keep for a
long time and your dad's a big star wars
fan he wanted to blurt it out
and that's a beautiful thing when you
guys you guys share star wars together
and you're like
he's living vicariously through you i
really love that i love that i wish you
know
it would have been nice if my dad was a
big superman fan and loved the comics
and then all of a sudden i became lex
luthor and he was like
oh my gosh that wasn't the case but let
me ask you real quick about
bokeh tan now in the clone wars your
sister
was uh the queen of mandalorin
yeah and she in the clone wars which are
amazing and everybody should watch
but uh big shout out to ethan and ken
and the star wars crew and joe spina
love you guys uh thank you ethan for
before you go into work on jeopardy
you talked to me a little bit about this
uh and
articulated it in a way that i can
understand um but
she was sort of had a relationship with
obi-wan kenobi sort of backstory
so now you're thrusted in this sort of
thing and she was murdered right she was
killed
so yeah by who paul right
darth maul right and so you
what's the story in a nutshell of the
the saber
the the saber where does that come from
the mandalorian
this are you not allowed to talk about
that no i can't talk about it
it's it's i you know i'm always so
scared i'm gonna screw up
so i have to think all right think for a
second these are questions that
sometimes i'll be like robin
right well get get robin get robin in
the room
robin robin come here i know this but i
don't want to screw it up
yeah need a reminder yeah baby
let me see robin hey
what you don't trust katie you got to
wear a mask no that's all the other guys
in here i got and this is just covering
my dirty
dog look how cute you are holy [ __ ] he's
adorable
i haven't told i don't think kate knows
this but i'm a huge fan here so
what smallville man i was that you're
the best character on that show
well you just made my day you did and
you know what if she sends me a
mandalorian character of bo katana
i'll send you a lex luthor doll
we'll do some trading hey let me ask you
she doesn't know she doesn't want to get
in trouble and by the way if you say
something
she doesn't know she just i do i second
guess myself so the
the dark saber was created by the jedi
by the first mandalorian jedi yes and
it is it is basically the ruler of
mandalore
has the dark saber that is sort of the
it's like the crown it's their staff
and you don't know where to get where it
is now that's what you're looking for
she
loses it all the time every every time
we hear with bokeh
and she's lost she's trying to find the
dark saber right you know um
yeah so because there's only ever been
one mandalorian jedi
that's as far as i know okay okay that
makes sense hey
robin real quick before you go uh what
was your favorite episode
of smallville smallville it's been so
long
i had the whole you know back in time i
had the whole box dv set my brother and
i
both had the whole dvd set watched every
episode back when i was
i don't know what was that yeah i love
you
i love you i would have been about 25.
that's about right when it was on
yeah you know what's funny is some
people i'm sure listening that are fans
of yours and not fans of mine are oh so
self-indulged he's talking about himself
i'm like
shut up this is a moment robin made me
happy
as you should man when your character
died it was the show just wasn't the
same
robin lex luthor never dies he never
will die
and he knows about the new lex luthors
and no one's no one's done it quite the
same man
yeah for me you're like the lex leaders
like james bonds
you're you're my uh my like sleeper
well i love you buddy you're a mensch
and i wish you guys the best
and it's going to be amazing i joked
with them
i joked with dave filoni the other day
that between
robin and him and my nerd cred
is getting better because my knowledge
of star wars between the two of them
just constantly is you know i was a fan
of
of of this world um but
i definitely needed to sit down and
understand it completely it's um
it's a huge vast world and um
um i wanted to respect it and and
because the fans are so loyal and the
story is so beautiful
so um things i didn't know
he helped fill in the blanks i'm weird
like that like i'll do some work
but i also like to get to set and it you
sort of if you inadvertently
like if you if you don't know what's
going on you almost create an ambiguity
to your character that you're like wow
he really feels like he doesn't know
like there's sort of like this you it's
almost like you're doing a different
character if you know too much you're
thinking too much because sometimes on
set they would say things like um
well that's the fortress of solitude i'm
like oh yeah
it sounds cool what's that oh my god
that's amazing it is oh wow
force of solitude is that something you
guys came up for this episode
uh no [ __ ] all right so lazad huh zod
who's this guy where's he from he's like
uh
well you're playing him it's an alter
wait you know it's just like
so it's just like i used to do the same
thing i need to be like if
i if my character wouldn't know it i
don't want it exactly
i think it was like a part of me that
didn't want to work hard enough
yeah of course it is i don't is this fun
i don't want to read the whole script
yeah and if it works keep working um for
now it's crazy now i you know
and dave said to me the other day he
said you know your knowledge
helps me write your character because
it it i know you're gonna come to set
and you're gonna know
what to do and i was like on set like
talking to like
john and dave and i was like no she
wouldn't do this because she knows this
person and she's that person and
they were like oh my god wow do you have
do you have jedi sheets
i had star wars sheets when i was a kid
my brother and i had bunk beds
with star wars sheets and i wish i still
had
those sheets because i saw a girl at a
convention years ago
that had a dress made out of the old
sheets and i was like that is the
coolest thing i've ever seen
that's so neat i have a like a 36 year
old
uh empire strikes back pillowcase
do you that's amazing i have our burton
ernie pillow cases still
i have those yeah that'd be weird though
if you're getting intimate and you're
like see burt and ernie i can understand
like star wars that's kind of like all
right
i could i could i could have sex to
c-3po i don't give a [ __ ]
just a big like big bird
if i put it in our child's bedroom
inside of you is brought to you from one
of my favorites uh echelon uh you know
other brand names are brought up to me
sometimes and i immediately
just charge in and go no what are you
talking about have you tried echelon
like whoa dude calm down bruh i'm like
i'm serious you gotta try echelon it's
cheaper than all those things
and they do more if you ask me i mean i
got the stationary bike with the monitor
i could ride
hundreds of miles with other people if i
got the mirror i could box and i could
stretch i got the rower
they've got so much great stuff echelon
and you're gonna get a good bargain
especially if you if you use our
our code today but uh i want to
personally thank echelon for
helping change my life and giving me
something to do so don't leave the house
i don't like to go for a run i like to
take my stationary bike and
and pretend i'm biking for miles on end
and
that's what i like to do ryan echelon
offers the next generation of connected
fitness bikes fitness mirrors rolling
machines and their echelon stride smart
treadmill no matter what your favorite
fitness activity echelon gives you a
fun and challenging workout from the
comfort of your own home
the ex-7s is echelon's latest
state-of-the-art innovation
that takes cycling to the next level the
ex-7s connected bike is built with
performance flexibility and durability
in mind the ex-7s
is the bike for competitors at heart and
their world-class instructors will
motivate you with thousands of daily
live and on-demand studio level classes
always available when you need them
unlike their competitors
echelon is affordable for everyone and
one membership lets up to five family
members all work out at the same
time come on right now you can try any
echelon fitness equipment at home
for 30 days i would suggest this go to
echelonfit.com
inside of you that's echelon
inside of you inside of you is brought
to you by helix
sleep helix i just love that name
if you're like me you don't sleep very
well your mattress is probably crappy
and it's time you got a new one i've had
enough damn surgeries in my life and
enough back pain and neck pain to know
that sleep is the most important thing
in the world
and i have the crappiest i'd call my
sleep craptastic
that's what i'd say but i needed a
mattress that just
was perfect for me and that's how i
found helix
it's so easy with helix because they
they want
you to be comfortable they want you to
have a better night's sleep and
obviously we're not being able to sleep
because
of the uh the pandemic the the politics
the the
you know our love life uh i sleep alone
with my dogs ryan but sleeping on a
terrible mattress or one that's not
right for you can ruin your life and all
of a sudden you start to get
problems i start when i have a bad
mattress my back starts to hurt
my neck starts to hurt and then i think
oh i have these problems but i'm like
well the problem is you're
you're f mattress everybody's unique and
helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium
firm mattresses great for cooling you
down if you sleep hot
yes helix and even the helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers
helix has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
so why would you buy a mattress made
from someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way
you sleep i took the helix quiz and i
found out that i'm really a medium
mattress sleeper
okay so that makes sense you don't want
something too firm you don't want
something it's like the porridge
it's like right there in the square in
the middle the square of the middle
that's what i said and i'm gonna stick
with it it's just a huge upgrade to what
i had
i i've had many mattresses i go through
mattresses like uh
don juan goes through you know it's just
that's just the thing i'm always looking
for the perfect mattress and right now
helix is that mattress for me i feel
incredibly comfortable on it and i have
a good night's sleep
delivery was fast and easy like i said
helix just wants to make life
easy for you so take the two minute quiz
get a
helix mattress and uh change your life
change mine
and helix was uh ranked number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights
risk free i have 98 nights left wow
that's a lot of good sleep
risk-free wow yeah will they pick it up
for me they will even pick it up for you
even if you don't love it
but you will so far so good
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattresses orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
inside you that's helix sleep.com
inside for up to 200
off and two free pillows helix sleep.com
slash
inside uh all right this is called [ __ ]
talking
with uh katie sackoff these are rapid
fire if you want if you feel like
talking a little more about them it's
fine
these are from my patrons who are
wonderful they get to ask questions
danny fantastic guest was it hard to get
into the headspace of your oculus
character it was such a demanding role
i interviewed mike flanagan i've
interviewed karen gillan i love them
both
um and that was a fan you were fantastic
in that you were so effed up
was it hard to get in that headspace no
you know i i thoroughly enjoy
um bringing as much physicality to my
characters as possible it's one of the
things that i
really enjoy um so when mike and i were
trying to figure out
how this woman would move when she was
possessed
i wanted her to move like an animal and
like really
like you know like as she's crawling and
like just and
try and like tweak my body in weird ways
and almost have it look like she's doing
parkour off the walls and things and he
was like if you could pull it off go for
it and i was like
what an amazing director to be like i
don't know have fun let's see if you can
do it
nobody better i i i think that guy is a
super talent and boy is he a humble
humble
man he's a genius yeah he um i remember
though when we were doing
i had to strangle my children and at the
time they were like 12 years old
and when i got the offer for the movie
it was written as like a
seven and eight year old and i remember
talking to
flanagan and being like i can't strangle
an eight-year-old
i i don't know if i can i don't know
that's amazing i just my mind was like i
don't
know because an eight-year-old there is
a very big difference
between a 12-year-old child actor and an
eight-year-old actor and i was like
i don't know if i can strangle an
eight-year-old actor like how do they
how do they'll be traumatized for the
rest of their life yeah get the girl who
played
orphan the girl in the orphan who's
supposed to be older but really playing
younger
then i could strangle the [ __ ] out of
her yeah yeah but instead
so they they hired this girl um annalise
basso who's
actually in that new um train
show it's the one with uh um
oh my god what's it called the the
frozen world
train thing where it moves across it's
ice on
we just watched it snow piercing no
piercer the movie
there's a show called snow piercer right
right
yeah it's um it's actually great we i i
just watched it but and they shot in the
same lot as another life but annelise
basso
um is in that show and she was 13 at the
time that she played my daughter and we
had a safe word
and the word was banana so if i was
strangling her too hard she had to say
banana
and this girl i barely had my hands at
her throat and
she had burned her face such a bright
red
that it looked she's literally a tomato
and they called
cut because they thought that she
couldn't get out the safe word and i was
like you guys i'm not even doing this
she's like she's turned her whole face
bright red
and they thought i was killing this
child oh my god
i thought you were going to say that she
was just really sensitive and choking to
the touch
could you imagine like she's like
ramsey jesus
dave p is there a dream role of yours in
any existing franchise tv film and in
uh or out of sci-fi oh my god
you know i get asked this question all
the time i bet you do alien wouldn't you
my i mean if if they could
of course i mean i grew up
idolizing sigourney weaver um
every role she's ever done every
character she's ever played i just
i there was something about
ripley that was so strong and capable
but so vulnerable and fragile
and i've i sort of modeled the strong
characters that i play or just learned
how to play strong characters
by watching her and that you know so
many times when women play a strong
character they
they play them very masculine and they
take away a lot of the feminine
qualities
that make women special and i think that
that vulnerability is such a key part of
the
the strength that these women possess
because
the strength and the vulnerability are
almost a yin and a yang
it's one exists because of the other um
and and that is what sigourney weaver
did
so well um
that was really well said i gotta tell
you that i mean that really just
because you know it's very hard there's
a very
thin line if you know you're going to
play it masculine you're going to lose
some of your audience maybe because
they're like
yeah but i still don't really care about
her as much so if you bring
both the strength and the weakness kind
of together
i think that not even female characters
i think in any character
except if you're playing like uh serial
killer or something for the most part
but even if you want to like somebody
you have to bring a little bit of
vulnerability in you have to bring
something that makes the audience
so it's not just one-dimensional right
yeah because the vulnerability is the
relatability that's the thing that
everybody goes oh yeah
yeah you know because we all have that
steph a
katie i loved you ever since battlestar
galactica
is there anyone in particular you miss
from the battlestar galactica days or do
you still keep in contact with
everyone oh my gosh you know i would say
that
we really do everyone keeps in touch um
um either you know as a big group or
or you know um personally like with each
other like trisha and i you know or
oh yeah edward james lady j i see him
all the time we were just texting the
other day
like i see mary all the time um uh
well not now obviously with kobe but um
um i just saw kate vernon love um
but no i so i don't know ron moore
probably ron moore
he's like the one person that i don't
see enough and
and i have been saying to him for years
that we've
we've got to find something else to do
together because i would love to work
but he's such a genius
and i've been watching outlander the
first couple seasons and i was like
this is like this is like softcore corn
oh wait can you put that on my tivo
the first the first season about the
first two seasons i was always like
oh my god and then robin would leave
town he's like are you watching
outlander and i was like
what um jennifer s loved you and
longmire did you feel that the 60-minute
drives
were no she didn't say that did you did
when you got lashed at did you no did
you feel it ended well longmire or did
you wish it would have gone for another
season or two
you know um i find that this is the case
with myself a lot of the times
um where i have been blessed to be on
two series now that have gone for six or
seven seasons or whatever
um and i find that you always need a
break
you know as an actor we want to bring as
many of these characters
characters to life as possible and i
think that one of the drawbacks of doing
a series is that you do
you do you become married to this one
character for
quite a long period of time if you're
lucky enough um
but one of the drawbacks is that you're
ready to sort of put it to bed when it
ends you know and i know on battlestar
galactica and longmire i was done i was
ready to be done
um but within a year i was like
i'd love to go back you know and i don't
want to go back to battlestar galactica
um i couldn't play starbucks anymore i
don't have that youthful angst
and that insecurity that um she had that
were required for that character you're
an actor katie you could get it back
you never know um but vic vic was the
closest i've ever played to myself
and i i learned so much on that
that show and i was proud of myself not
only for the growth
of of my acting ability on the show but
the growth of me
personally during that time and those
people
um were instrumental in helping me
mold the person that i am now and when
we left longmire we actually thought we
were going to do movies
um so we just sort of went all right
cool we'll we'll be back
and it just didn't work out um but we
all see each other once a year we
we go to longmire days in wyoming it's
like a big
huge um sci-fi convention but for
longmire really just for longmire oh my
god
it is insane it's not 10
000 people descend on buffalo wyoming
10 000 people it's insane
and we go and they put us up with this
ranch and we don't get paid for it but
they put the ranch
they pay for our trip out there and we
hang out with the fans we go to
dances in the square we sign autographs
we
go horseback riding and skeet shooting
and hiking and
it is so much fun and and robert flies
over from australia with his whole
family and everyone brings their whole
families there can i be part of your
family
can i you should come when the cove is
over can you just bring me
it's so much fun and they're like well
who's this guy like well i i emailed him
about a potential role
this is family anyone you've known for
20 years
it's family and i think we're almost
there i i feel like you know i i have
such add that
i do a pilot for something like that's
great moving on let's go
one season can we alright let's move on
let's do i i'm just like
i feel like okay i've done this it's
very hard for me to continue and
continue and continue
it's just but now that they have those
eight to ten episodes a year
it's more doable manageable you can do
other things i just doing the same thing
for eight to ten months a year
anything like i need a break from
podcasts you do two podcasts in a week
you don't do it for a week
you know you do anything i think people
get tired of everything that the
monotony builds in but uh
22 episodes is hard oh that was brutal i
said this and
um i still stand by this that i would
never do 22 episodes again
never never would do it i could do it i
couldn't do it no it would
no i couldn't do it that would kill us
kill us
i'm too old beth b love the appearances
on big bang theory do you find it more
fun to play in comedy or drama setting
um i actually love doing comedy um
i love it more i don't get the
opportunity um i think i've done
i've done it twice um and it's it's just
not something that people think of
me for you know i'm the person that
they're like we need someone to punch
them in the face let's call katie
um yeah it's not yeah it's just um
it's one of the reasons why i
started the youtube channel with with
robin and i started that like two years
ago now
what's it called it's just my name um
it's just katie sanchez we're very
creative go on youtube look up katie
sack off check her [ __ ] out please
um but we did it because i i wanted to
be lighthearted and
fun and joke around and be my dorky
stupid self
which is crazy and so we knew that
i probably wouldn't get the opportunity
so we created the youtube channel you
know what i'll say
i'll say that um as much as i love
comedy
and i find it easier it's to me it's
more of a pain in the ass
that i've done both yeah as when i do
something serious
they're done in two takes we're moving
on
in comedy they want oh can you hit this
line here all of a sudden i'm like i'm
not funny anymore you've done 10 takes
on my close-up
now you're doing 10 ticks on her tent
it's like we get trying to find
something either write better [ __ ]
and let me i mean i i can't i can't read
it
it just takes way i thought it would be
so quick let's just do a setup and let
you know let it play and we'll do a wide
and a little pop poppity pop and
go have lunch and i'm like [ __ ] this is
exhausting this isn't fun
comedy's fun drama is easier for me i
think
drama is a lot easier a lot easier and
when you said that
i literally just remembered and i don't
know how and we talked about this the
last time i was on your podcast
um that the first time i ever booked was
your show
and i totally forgot that until this
moment
i forgot what year was that 1998
on zoe duncan jack and jane yeah we had
to make out
it's someone we had to make out yeah we
talked about that you'll have to listen
to the first podcast but what's great
about this you could
see katie if you're listening make sure
you subscribe on the youtube channel not
only to katie but to my podcast and you
could watch this video
and ryan's here and he edits them and
he's fantastic but that's right we did
with selma blair who i just interviewed
and david moscow and uh azura skye
and it was a fun little show it didn't
last long but we had fun it was
definitely fun and i was an idiot and i
was young and who knows
last question idiot too i think i dated
david moscow for like a day
real after the show how did he get your
number
where did this come from i think i did
i did what happened to me
robin okay rozzy what set did you have
fun on the most battle star
24 or mandalorian i know what she's
going to say
oh maybe definitely definitely yes
definitely
definitely definitely definitely first i
mean and if we're just talking about
like take the subject matter out of it
um take the
the show out of it completely and just
what show i had the most fun on it would
still
be the mandalorian i i had so much fun
working um with mercedes who plays
uh who's sasha banks the the wrestler um
and um she plays kosuka and we had such
a great time
together getting to know each other talk
about hard workers like that girl
would she would
go fight friday nights for wwe
take off her blue like her blue hair
would be
woven in she'd take that off get on a
plane flight overnight
get her coast gua hair sewn in
um when she got to the hotel she would
come to work she would work for like
three days and then she would get on a
plane and flight back for another fight
that weekend i mean it was
crazy
but off well this has been an absolute
treat did you have fun
i did of course i felt so bad you know
when we did our talk about learning
lessons right
when we did our podcast last time i
remember texting you and being like i am
so
worried after i listened to it we had
such a great talk but
my my language was so
bad and i swore left right center the
entire time
i don't remember that back i realized i
was like i need to stop this
this is really insane i do this all i
swear
so much um and it made me sort of
pull back on my cussing because it got
out of control there for a second so
hang on
so that incident on longmire made you a
better person
and then me cr you swearing on my
podcast made you a less
a better yeah non-swear you know
it's all about growth here i love it
well listen what's your handle on
instagram so people can follow you
at the real katie sackoff
k-a-t-i-e-s-a-c-k-o-f-o-e-e
[ __ ]
[Music]
hof i'm not a great speller it's okay
it's got
my name is spelled weird and i've got a
silent h in it it's like
it's okay well it'll be fine but listen
i love you
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you again thank you for not cursing
although i don't care
but i'm glad i could help and uh keep
kicking ass
thank you it was so good to see you stay
safe and
sane and all of it well i'll stay safe
i know sanity it's already it's already
gone i'm drunk from
i mean as soon as it hits 4 45 i'm like
close enough
yeah hey and email me your address and
i'll send him something
he can't hear me yeah do it seriously no
idea rosie i had no idea
i love that i love that he has the
confidence as well
to be like obsessed i would do that too
if i saw somebody that
i didn't care if anybody knew him or
whatever i'm like that i would go oh my
god you were
the the pilot and dawn of the dead you
died and your zombie was so cool
i know yeah anyway i love it all right i
don't know what i'm talking about all
right you're the best
yeah he's amazing all right so thank you
you got it it was awesome bye bye see
you wouldn't want to be
you
[Laughter]
you know now that i saw the show i wish
that i would have interviewed her after
i'd seen it because i cried in the
finale i was like
so amazing and she's so good and uh
yeah so again everybody who's listening
who love katie sack off on the podcast
if you came for katie
please subscribe and give us a chance
and listen to the podcast
um and write a review thank you to
westwood one thank you to ryan my
engineer and editor
couldn't do it without him or bryce or
my dog in the background barking i
couldn't do it without her
erv's getting um he's getting old as we
know my my dog and
uh you know it's it's getting sad i
think i'm getting uh
you know they say when you're taking
care of a sick one that you go through
depression you go through a lot of
stress and i feel that i feel like you
know i'll give him anything in the world
but like you know there comes a time
where
i hate that when that day comes but
we'll have to say hey man you've had
enough buddy
and i think he'll give me that look like
dude i'm [ __ ] i'm done i'm done i've
had a good life let me go let me go to
dogs the dog heaven and uh
if anybody's going to heaven it's dogs
if you ask me animals
animals are you know they're the front
of the bus with heaven
god's like what are you i'm a human
sorry no
um fido's in front of you
[Laughter]
mother freaker uh thank you again
everybody thanks to my dear patrons who
you don't realize but you make this show
possible more than you can imagine
i sent a bunch of merch if it didn't get
to you or if it's really taped badly
i'm sorry uh write to hello at inside of
you podcast
and um i'll do what i can
um i hope you like the boxes i'm giving
you stuff
new merch is coming out on the inside of
you online store
uh we're doing a white out so i'm
getting white tumblers
white mugs and white shirts okay i just
thought it'd be cool
so uh that will be happening soon once
they arrive and uh
but thank you patrons in fact why don't
i read all my lovely patrons right now
and i know uh ryan can do it but today
we'll we'll not do it but
i need a break he needs a break nancy d
haven't gotten the pillows yet that's
not
my fault or your fault i don't know what
happened uh leah asks
hi stubs trisha f sarah v little lisa
you keep go
jill e brian h lauren g nico p robin s
jerry w emily f robert b jason w stephen
j kristen k
amelia oh allison l jess j lucas m
raj c joshua d emily s cjp
samantha m jennifer n jackie p i miss
saying hamza
huh stacy l carly h jennifer asks
janelle b
carrie b tava the 272 not to be confused
with top of the 273
ashley k kimberly e crystal h mike e
marissa and
el dons supremo elden supremo
that's fun ladies and gentlemen el don
supremo
jackass ramirez
beth b santiago m sarah f chad w liam p
rashan roshan or sroshan
roshan roshan roshan we talked
we had a zoom it was beautiful cameo
zoom ray a
maya p maddie s tiffany i kendrick f
ashley e shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v james r chris
h
a new should w
h amy c dave h samantha s spider-man
chase sheila g
ray h alyssa c tabitha t
uh we got misha h we've got a lot of
newbies here
sweet deb a tom and natalie 622 not to
be confused with 63. suzanne b henry s
kdf liliana a hi liliana we just did a
zoom with you two and your kiddos
michelle king what's up mark cuz he's
the coolest
marcus marcus he's cool
hannah b michael s talia m luke h john s
andrew t christie s claire m liz j
laura l chad b rachel e and nathan
e what a lovely bunch of people thank
you
uh patrons i'm doing my q a um that a
lot of you sent
questions in um join patreon if you
haven't joined patreon
uh it's a wonderful thing and it's a
family and uh some people get merch
boxes and letters written
uh by me and uh others get to ask
questions on the on the podcast [ __ ]
talking questions to the guests and
lots of other stuff but anyway thank you
guys so much for listening as always and
watching and
um i love doing it so i'm gonna keep
doing as long as you guys
want me to do it so uh from ryan and
myself here in
the canyons yeah why don't we close out
with a little summertime neighbor
okay here we go can you hear that oh
yeah so this is the uh
the song that i'm doing the video for
we'll just listen to a little bit
[Music]
it's got a good beat to it doesn't it
good vibe feels like summertime
anyway thank you guys ryan give it a
wave
uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you
until next time thank you